guys big news here in Tennessee today as
the Tennessee legislature just passed
the House and Senate passed a bill which
bans child mutilation in the state of
Tennessee what that means is that
there's not going to be any more
mutilating of children in an effort to
quote unquote reassign their gender uh
no more irreversible surgeries no more
cross-sex hormones and puberty blockers
that's all now illegal in the state of
Tennessee as it should be in every other
state and and there are increasingly you
know numbers of states that are that are
making all this stuff illegal which
which tells us that we are winning in
the fight against gender ideology we're
winning in the Fight Against Child Abuse
um we have the momentum you know we have
them on their heels and we are
protecting children in a real and
quantifiable way so I want to thank you
as daily wire members if you're not a
member yet
um this is a good reason to jump on
board and be a part of this because like
I said the Fight Continues there's a
whole lot more to be done so we're
getting back to work